The hippie trail of the 1960s promised something rare freedom.
Thousands of young souls packed their backpacks, left behind the suffocating weight of cubicles and clocks,
and set off toward Kathmandu, convinced they were shedding their old skins.
But the self, it turns out, is heavier than a rucksack.
By the time they reached the Himalayas, they found the same walls just painted in different colors.
The cage had only changed shape.
Now we've refined the art of escape.
Digital nomadism sells itself as the ultimate liberation.
Work from a cafe in Lisbon, sip cocktails on Bali's beaches,
write code from Medellin's Misty Hills All,
while the world assumes you've cracked the code of effortless living.
But here's the truth.
It's the geography of nowhere, a life designed to be frictionless, yet guaranteed to leave you adrift.
You've traded one prison for another, just with better Wi-Fi.
Behavioral science calls it asterisk hedonic adaptation.
Move to paradise, and your happiness baseline drags along like an anchor.
Three weeks in, the turquoise water of the Mediterranean isn't a postcard its wallpaper.
Six weeks in, you're just as miserable in a hammock as you were in that ergonomic chair back home.
The dream fades faster than a sunburn.
So how do you perfect the illusion?
Follow the instructions.
First, master asterisk the community exit.
Seek out places where you don't speak the language, where the history is a foreign script.
Limit your social circle to other nomads people who, like you, are temporary,
who fear commitment like a bad Wi-Fi signal.
You'll never belong, but at least you'll never be alone.
Not really.
Then, embrace asterisk the productive vacation fallacy.
Tell yourself you can have it all a career that thrives, an adventure that never ends.
The result?
You spend your days in Bali hunting for a stable connection,
your nights in the office fretting over your tan.
You're neither working nor exploring.
You're just waiting for the next thing to distract you from the fact that you're exactly where you were before,
just with a different view.
Next, fall into asterisk, the minimalist trap.
Asterisk.
Strip your life down to a single backpack.
Convince yourself this is freedom.
But what you're really doing is erasing yourself.
Your books, your tools, the artifacts of who you were.
You become a ghost in the system, moving through spaces without leaving a trace.
And the system?
It doesn't even notice you're gone.
Finally, live for, asterisk, the Instagram buffers.
Every experience must be documentable.
If you see a sunset and don't post it, did it even happen?
You turn every moment into a production, ensuring you're never truly present.
You're always performing the life you think you should be living, never the one you're actually in.
And what's the endgame?
You become a asterisk continental ghost, asterisk continental ghost,
someone who belongs everywhere and therefore belongs nowhere.
You achieved asterisk mobile misery,
the ability to be unhappy in any time zone, at any altitude, in any currency.
Technology has given you the power to carry your dissatisfaction with you,
no matter where you go.
The nomad's burden is simple.
You're always worrying about asterisk, next Tuesday,
the next flight,
the next Airbnb,
the next coffee shop.
You never hear.
You're always preparing to leave.
As the old saying goes,
travel is a fool's paradise.
If we are not at home when we travel,
we will not be at home when we return.
And the worst part?
You'll keep chasing the horizon anyway.